let me put it this way i do think we
have moved the ball forward i think the
mayor has basically driven reform very
very hard and successfully here in New
York we have a lot more to go I mean if
you ask me you know sort of in the
process we are still in the early stages
I guess you know if you if you think of
Churchill's words this is not the
beginning of the end but the end of the
beginning and that's where I think we
are but a lot more work has to be done I
think the basic things that have changed
the system is we conceptualize the model
that we're now implementing based on
leadership accountability and
empowerment which is very different from
the typical models that have permeated
public education what do I mean by that
the first thing which i thought was our
most successful concepcion was we
stopped talking about a great school
system and started talking about a
system made up of great schools because
school is where the action is and if you
don't get that and you talk about
systems systems are political systems or
managerial but they're not where service
is delivered to kids and so then we
started to focus heavily on the human
resource equation getting great
principals making sure principles could
hire the teachers they want in the past
before I got here 3500 3000t chures
would show up each year at a different
school and say I have a legal right to
be here and if the principal or the
other teacher said well you're not the
right fit for the school didn't matter
that's all changed we're now using
incentives to help principles in
high-need schools attract talent so
fundamentally what we've tried to do is
create a system where schools become the
unit and the schools are empowered to
make decisions by the same token we put
a letter grade on every school we hold
our schools accountable for progress not
for what the kid brings to the school or
what the school does for the kids so we
compare similarly situated schools and I
think that those three pillars
leadership empowerment and
accountability have really changed the
fundamental paradigm
our city the things there are certain
things that we have done some things we
didn't implement well that I wish we had
a better shot at if you ask me the
lesson that I wish I had learned sooner
is I don't think we've been as effective
and engaging our community and making
sure that people in the city knew what
the changes were about we let other
people characterize changes in a way
that I think is both inaccurate and and
harmful and I think we could have done a
better job engaging parents in the
school system making them feel like they
were strongly elide with what we're
doing believe in the work we're doing
because I think most of the parents in
our city understand the schools are
getting better recent survey showed that
in every income group poor near poor and
moderate and high income and all three
of those groups an independent survey
showed that the number of parents who
say their kids in an a or b school has
gone up and in the poor and near-poor
went up very significantly and even
moderate middle went up about eight
points but in poor went from 24 to
sixty-four percent of the parents over
the course of the mayor's terms so
that's huge but I think we did not do as
good a job as we should have engaging
them in if you will the politics of
educational transformation
what I'd like to see is a mayor who will
keep the campaign going I've always said
I serve in appointed positions that's
where I am most comfortable but I'd look
forward to the opportunity to work with
another mayor and keeping moving forward
public education in the city in New York